it's very nice for me to be here in as
well because my indeed my alma mater is
einthoven University and it's very nice
to be back
yeah I've not spent so much time on
myself I'm a researcher and I research
process mind this is something different
from the commercial applications that
you often see in process mining so if
you heard about process mining and you
know about slowness slowness and
Academical process mining is not the
same thing that's something I usually
like to stress and I'm not going to
details about that Academical debate if
you want to know more about my research
please visit my home page where I list a
lot of my blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
publications I will briefly talk about
process mining so what it is how how I
look at process mining essentially and
then I will show you a bit of how to do
it in Python and I would like to start
by focusing on this notion of process
which is a very important thing in
process mining and I want to take you
through that notion of processes by
means of what I kind of did this morning
so in order to get to the stage I
executed a few activities the most
painful activity since I live in AK in
these days which is in Germany and it's
not very close to either Venus I had to
wake up relatively early to be here in
time and then as you see I'm all dressed
so I had to take a shower I wanted to be
fresh and took a shower and I put on my
clothes i I had I had some small
breakfast brushed my teeth in the end I
also drove here and I was very unlucky
because this highway the a2 had a little
block so I was almost too late actually
and finally I'm here with the microphone
in my collar so when we look at all
these things these are kind of all you
could say activities like while waking
up is an activity that tends to take a
long time but I try to be good for the
environments or a shower relatively far
etc so all of these activities that have
a duration but moreover more importantly
there are some sometimes explicit and
sometimes implicit relations among these
activities so for example I prefer to
first have my breakfast and then brush
my teeth this is not really necessary
but I usually do it like that and what
it's more necessary is that I take a
shower first before putting on my
clothes because if I would do it the
other way around that will not be so
convenient obviously I cannot do
anything of this prior to be actually
awake and finally you don't want to
maybe you do but I assume you don't want
to see me present him naked so I did all
these things before I was here so that
comes to the conclusion that a process
in process mining is actually a
collection of activities that we perform
in order to achieve certain goal and the
goal of my example was to be here today
and to talk to you guys but when we look
in a more abstract sense to processes in
organisations you can think of a lot of
goals that a company might have but
what's really important is that when I
talk about processes and when I talk
about process mining I talk in the end
about analyzing as we will see later the
data that's coming from this type of
processes and more mathematically
inclined people will probably know and I
assume all of you are that these are
discrete processes so I'm not really
talking that in that sense of about
continuous processes although you can of
course discretize continuous processes
into this form so what types of
processes can you think of outside of my
morning routine
think of logistics think of sending a
package to a customer from our warehouse
and when we do that during the let's say
journey of the the package there will be
several times in which this package is
being scanned think of mortgage for
example think of financial institutions
where if I want to buy a house I need a
mortgage and to do so I need to go to
the bank and the bank nun has to decide
whether I'm allowed to get this mortgage
yes or no so what will happen is when I
go to the bank and have a talk with
someone someone believe the bank that
employee the system of the bank at set
we'll start to execute a process to
determine whether I'm allowed to get
this mortgage or not also you can think
about the hospital or the medical domain
where actually we treat patients we
execute activities in order to achieve
the goal of let's say getting the
patient out of the hospital preferably
alive and you can think of more
electronic oriented you can think of
customers going to a web shop browsing
pages adding stuff to their basket and
in the end receiving goods so all these
process have a common modern day in the
model world these processes have
something in common which they don't
have in common with my example process
so when I woke up this morning and when
I did my things to get here I didn't
record anything I did these things just
happened and I never there's no data but
in one of the information systems what
you typically see is that a lot of the
activities that we perform in the
context of any of these processes are
actually stored in side of the
information system of the companies and
in process mining obviously because it's
a very data-driven thing to do we
analyze these data tables that you see
here on the right hand side of the slide
and I'll briefly explain later how this
data looks and how we work with that but
keep in mind data that we analyzed the
process mining is always assumed to be
coming from the execution of a primarily
discrete process so the mining phase for
all of you should be very very natural
that meaning it's exactly like this but
then what we do is we do it like this so
what you see on the left hand side is
you see a guy that is trying to find
valuable information out of this raw
rock and you is using a tool for that
and essentially that's what we do in
process mining as well so the rock is
kind of this raw data that you see in
the information system of the company
the machine would be your laptop or your
server running at Hadoop or sparkless or
whatever preferably with Python but ok
you can also use Java whatever you want
and then the guys essentially this data
scientist having a lot of fun in his job
so process mining if you would like
quantify it in one sentence it's about
obtaining knowledge of an insights in
processes by means of analyzing the
event data generated during the
execution of the process now why am I
saying this is very important because
you always have to keep in the back of
your mind in my view when you do
something with process mining related
technology that in the end what you want
is to get more knowledge and more
insights in a process in order to make
it better
I think in general in data science
that's always what you want to do you
want to generate somehow and knowledge
out of some raw block of data in order
to streamline something when in this
case is processes and I have to mention
specifically that this knowledge and
insights is something what's really
important in the context of process
mining so the analysis we do on the base
of data in the end we try to communicate
this with real stakeholders with people
so it's often doesn't suffice to just
train a neural network and then say
here's your neural network have fun
predicting ok so let's briefly look at
the data and let's assume and I will be
using a sort of running example in my
presentation and let's assume we own
some some Spore and we sell some packets
on some some gifts for Christmas and
what we're doing in our warehouse is
we're we're putting these Christmas
gifts into boxes and shipping them to
our customers and then when I would look
into the data or into the information
system of my company in a simplified way
what I would see is something like this
I have three columns one listing the
unique ID of an order that someone
placed to get a new new toy for ask it
that's the first column the second
column is the activity is what activity
has been performed for that specific
order and the third column represents at
what point in time so if we look a bit
closer to this data we see that for an
order identified by set HT 4 5 7 4 6 5 8
there were three activities performed
apparently yesterday in European Time
fifteen past five twelve to six and nine
to six and these activities are create
order add item submit order for those of
you that have been working with more
sequential orient data this is somehow
the same type of data that you would use
the sequential pattern mining but the
difference is that you only use
Singleton's rather than sets of
arbitrary size so if we look at this
other order you see that and all was
created and an item was added so this is
the type of data that we work with and
we want to do a few things with the data
gaining knowledge and insights in the
process so what do we do there is a few
there are a few other things that we do
but today I'm specifically focusing on
two subtasks that we do in process
mining because these are both supported
by the Python framework that I've also
briefly talked about whereas some more
advanced techniques are not yet there
in general we have two so we have two
core components which are process
discovery and conformance checking I
will explain each of them with a simple
example and later I'll show how to do
that in Python
so first let's focus on process
discovery it is analogous exactly to
this taking a picture like satellite
picture out of the sky and drawing a map
this is literally what process discovery
is all about and as I said before here
again you see a process a map like this
of this Geographic data is intended for
us to reason about what we see in the
real world and that's very important
that's also what we really want to do in
process discovery so this map on the
right hand side really helps me to
understand the picture I see on the left
at the same time there are some
limitations that are also inherently
there when you apply this on real data
that is that if you look at this picture
it's just a let's say a snapshot it's
not the total surroundings of einthoven
so
in my picture I will also not see the
total surroundings and finally and this
is the same when you apply this process
discovery in real data if you extract
data from an information system it does
not necessarily show the full process
I was recently involved in a study where
we were analyzing repairs of large scale
energy energy production facilities and
that the repair itself was not not
locked in the information system and
that often happens that certain parts of
the process are not visible and the same
on this picture I can see the outsides
of the buildings I cannot see what is
inside a building and this is the same
in in real data if I see that a resource
is working it can be a human or a
machine I do not necessarily know if
it's working slow what is the underlying
cause it could be that this person is
depressed what could be that this person
is also involved in a lot of other
processes so that's why I like this
analogy so if I apply that on the data I
showed you and if I would generate a bit
more data and then actually what we get
is a picture that looks like this it's
important to realize these algorithms do
that completely automatically but since
I'm talking at a PI data conference I
guess you guys understand that very well
so we push in a table with with hundred
thousand millions of these rows and we
get them all like this so what does this
model tell us in this case I don't know
if anyone here is familiar with the
notion of Petri Nets this is sort of the
form of battery net essentially this
says that on the basis of the data that
I've given to the algorithm any any of
these orders in our warehouse starts
with a create order activity after that
you should see an item being added to
the order and potentially such item can
be removed and you can also add multiple
items and then at some point you decide
to submit the order and now it's
interesting and what's also very
difficult in process mining and process
discovery is that if we go a bit further
and I walk to the other side here this
is a block of concurrent
or parallel behavior and what you see
here is that sending the invoice and
potentially sending some reminders it's
something that we do as a company it's
our warehouse doing that at the same
time but it's related to customer
contact at the same time if you look at
the bottom you see that we also need to
check the store potentially order the
boots and finally pack the order and
this is something that can happen
completely independent of each other so
I can do sending the invoice at the same
time as check store before or after it
and the same for sending reminders it's
completely independent of each other and
then finally you either cancel dispatch
the order and close the order and why
I'm highlighting this is that you have
to realize that if you are able to
schedule activities in a concurrent
construct like this the number of ways
in which you can permute permits these
different activities in which you can
schedule them grows factorial e so if
you have 10 activities in parallel and
you could easily draw that on the slide
here it generates millions and millions
of different sequences you can generate
so this process discovery to relate it
back to more classical data mining it's
actually very very difficult and I'll
try to illustrate why so this example
that I show you here is based on very
clean synthetic data and I get this
beautiful picture but if I do this in
the real world I'm just going through
this information system and extracting
the data the problem is that the models
we want to mine are models that just
describe how the process is supposed to
execute to be executed and in such a way
that it's supported by the statistics we
see in the data however often we see in
the data several data quality problems
you see that stuff is locked incorrectly
sometimes the login is correct but the
execution is not okay then the first
thing that can happen is sometimes stuff
is very infrequently executed
still correct so what I said before if
you have parallel activities and you
have millions of ways to schedule this
it's not necessarily the case even
though this is possible that you will
see everything so in a way if you just
extract data and apply these techniques
what you're essentially doing is trying
to learn either the set entry of or a
neural network or whatever to classify
whether people smoke or not without
providing providing the actual label of
whether someone smokes or not so it's
not even a single class prediction type
of thing you're doing if you do it on
raw data it's it's an unknown class
prediction type so it's extremely
difficult and recent research also shows
one of the PC psycho supervise that if
you want to pre-process this data in a
completely autonomous automated way this
is almost impossible to do because you
cannot really distinguish easily between
infrequent correct behavior and
infrequent incorrect behavior etc so of
course this picture is nice but I think
also if you're looking commercial
application of process mining you will
often see that they don't support
finding concurrency in this way and this
is just because it's just not so simple
as a scientist is great because it's
it's fun to try to solve difficult
problems now let's take a look at
conformist checking conformist checking
is essentially what you see on this
picture usually I have to explain this
picture because I'm also talking a lot
about in the Netherlands this picture is
if you were talking on Islands for most
people this picture is clear what you
see here is of course a pedestrian area
and the government kind of has a
reference model that tells us this is
what is what you're supposed to do or
what you're not supposed to do and
obviously what we're not supposed to do
is cycle here yet reality which is the
equivalent here of the data shows us
otherwise and this is something that is
still a core kind of thing that we can
do in process mining but again it's
again alleviating on data and and trying
to show value but it's much further of a
classical data mining in a sense so
computing statistics like this so let's
let's take a look again
assuming of this order where we see that
first order was created then item was
removed and then the item was added that
that's weird because as I hope you
remember that and I'll show you a few
slides back what we try to do is always
first create an order then add an item
and then optionally we can remove an
item or add more items so what we see
here is creating the order then removing
an item is not possible according to
data then we see an ADD item activity
and an assent invoice and these
conformist taking techniques they allow
us to compute whether or not these
executions are actually in line with
that process model or not so for example
if I would feed this type of algorithms
this sequence of data for this order ID
it would essentially tell me that this
add item activity here should be in
between because I cannot remove items
that will never add it and at the same
time it will also recognize that to be
able to do the same invoice I should
first have a submit order now the this
is as I said it's not such a classical
data mining technique at the same time
to compute these statistics we actually
use a lot of artificial intelligence
type of algorithms so for the more
people that are bit into that field if
you want to compute a explanation of
such a trace in terms of such a model
what you're actually doing is you're
solving the shortest path problem on the
state space of that model in conjunction
actually with a model of that trace so
you make a more refined model of the
combination of the two you compute the
state space and you do for example a
star on this now the problem is that I
just told you if you have a model which
is is having a lot of parallels in the
state space is huge typically we try to
use models that do not have an infinite
state space although there are ways to
cope with infinite state spaces there
okay so essentially as I said you can
see where deviations
are by computing this type of statistics
what also of course we use this somehow
if you have a event data set and you
learn a model using process discovery we
also use these artifacts to compute how
well does this model describe the
behavior we see in the event log so if
everything would be green you have in a
way recall of one we usually usually
call this replay Fitness but it's
actually sort of equivalent metric to
recall
okay so process mining and this
consisting of discovery and confirm is
checking as I said there are some
alternative techniques as well so
there's all kinds of techniques that
allow you to for example plot the
execution of historical data onto a
mobile to visualize that there's also
all kinds of techniques that kind of
figure out if there's choices in a
process which data attributes relate to
that such a choice but that's more like
solving a classical data mining problem
I want to now focus early on doing this
in Python because yeah this is a Python
pythonic conference so we started like
roughly one year ago we start this pm4
py library process mining for Python the
website that you reach now if you go
here is the old website which is very
funny to look at because it's this
typical Academical very ugly website it
does not have the first logo but this
logo we have here is still extremely
ugly we try to make it a bit more
professional but our main task is
actually writing papers so we have
little time to do that so this this is a
library that essentially tries to
implement process discovery algorithms
in and process mining algorithms sorry
in Python the actual intent initially
was really to support academics actually
because we we noticed that there were a
lot of algorithms that we would like to
use in our research that were only
available in Python and there was no
proper library
to do these type of things we're now
also building some web based so it's
flasks and angular we're building some
web-based client on top of this but
that's not open source so the only the
basic library is open source so let's
look at some things we can do in this
data so in this library
first of all loading data we support
also Park add files I believe but I just
listed CSV which is very known to most
people so if I take a look at this
example data set in CSV this would be
kind of looking something like this
where the first column is again this
order ID it's called case then we see
events timestamp we have actually start
complete time we have also resource
information those really matter so if
you have data set with mostly important
if you have a data set that at least has
such a case column or such order ID
column you have events and you have your
at least start and/or end time you can
kind of use this library so try to
remember what you need to do process
mining and then rather than being too
technology-driven try to solve a problem
with the technology that really fits the
problem so if you have this type of data
you might be able to do something with
this technology then if you would like
to load that into PM 4 py
you can just essentially import the
factory of the PM for python objects
that lurked on imported csv class
actually I used the name Factory
initially when I was I started this
library and I was then looking I was
building something I was using a factory
a design pattern for that and then
somehow some people joined the the
consortium and started to greatly
adopting this factory idea but these
factories that we have now invite in in
our framework are actually not so much
of a factory software design pattern
anymore so we might
in future change the name of this
factory to something like entry point or
algorithm but anyway so if you implement
this CSV log import what you essentially
need to do is to say C is V log inputs
don't apply you do the path to the file
and then if you would do that
essentially it's loaded so this is
usually it's just loaded as some pandas
dataframe depends a bit alternatively
you can use xes this is a let's say
international standard for process
mining data it's an XML based storage
format and as you can see the difference
here although I didn't explicitly
highlight that in the previous slide is
that in a previous slide you can put so
let's say in CSV it doesn't matter if
you have an order and and it's followed
by different orders and then you have
something that relates to the same order
again that doesn't matter
because they're the gluing the different
activities together it's really done on
the basis of the values so what I'm
trying to say is it could be that in
between these two events here there's a
lot of different stuff for example for
case 63 that doesn't really matter this
storage format first already groups all
the different events related to the same
case into into one node essentially in
the tree so this everything you see here
relates to the order with mid name or ID
two three six however I just wanted to
show actually that in CSV importing what
you need to do is type this then if you
want to import such a file the only
thing same thing to change this CSV
becomes xes and then that's it however
as I said because we in a Access file
store the data on a case-by-case level
rather on event by event level if you
here print this
the zeroth element of our event data
it's actually a complete sequence of
yeah it's a complete sequence of events
already rather than having the events
individually so this is all the events
related to case two three six this is
these are all the events related to case
six three okay so if you want to do
process discovery it gets a bit more
involved we have again our xes file
import in this case and we have an
discovery algorithm which is called the
inductive miner there are several
different discovery algorithms available
so there's also a miner called the Alpha
- so if you would swap inductor for
alpha the main usage of the framework
remains the same so essentially what you
need to do is you say I want to discover
and process model these two markings
please ignore them it's just some side
side product that that you get because
the models we discover up a tree nets
which you need these side objects
however if I run this I simply get of
course I just get an object back back
this process model is stored in an
object so if I want to visualize the
Petri net I also need to import a Petri
net visualization Factory and
essentially pushed the model into that
here so here I make a visualisation by
applying the visualizer Factory with the
model the marking and I say I wanted SVG
and then if I call the view method I can
essentially get this model so with these
few lines of code you can except
actually translate a data set into such
a process model which is nice because
for those who ever used something with
process mining and those who ever used
with prom framework which was written in
Java you would need to do a lot more so
in the case you would like to use CSV
instead of
xes what you essentially need is you
need a bit more so actually it's not so
much that is changing with respect to
discovering on the base of xes however
you need to specify to the algorithm
which column is used to represent the
case so which column is would be the
order and which column is the actual
event and then if you do that yeah so
what you typically most likely it will
just I think it will just keep it the
order as a zip file but it depends a bit
so colleague of mine has also been
playing around with pandas dataframes so
initially what I built is that I would
literally I made an interface that's
essentially it's just a list so you
could apply this destacia of lambda
functions so my idea was okay if you
want to sort it on any attribute that is
commonly present you just write to
lambda function on this advant dog and
it automatically works because you know
it is like this so for that date that
interface that I wrote it's still the
case for a data frame it could be that
he already does some pre filtering for
you but sometimes you have multiple time
stamps and it depends a bit on the way
you want to see it some data you can
look at it in different ways there's
different case notions and then maybe
for one case notion you need
timestamp X and for the other case no
she needs I'm someone yeah so here you
see roughly in the input data that I was
using I'm saying to this are going use
this as a case identify use this at but
a good question obviously you want it to
be sorted on time if you do and I would
get against a model then finally to wrap
up if you want to do confirm is checking
well what you're essentially need to do
is you need to get your event data you
need to get a model you can of course
also use a model
you discover whatever you want and then
you can compute what we call alignments
and alignments are these explanations
that I explained earlier of trace event
data into in the context of a process
model and then you would get some output
like this where it says the create order
was matched correctly onto the model
then an add item was correctly matched
and a submit order this is essentially
for routing purposes so this says ignore
me and then send invoice was okay here
you see that somehow the order Goods
activity has not been recorded in the
data as it should we also have some
visualizations of these type of
artifacts but I didn't put it in the
slides
so again if you're interested in
applying process mining and you want to
use Python then please consider using
our open source process mining platform
and yeah that was kind of what I wanted
to share with you today
[Applause]